well a little change of scenery I'm in
the other car this is of course you
could tell this is the car that we use
to cart the kids around in because well
first of all they're the crumbs all over
the seat and also whatever that thing is
right there I didn't know what that is
but but mainly the main piece of
evidence is this the stickers on the
window here because and and you know
this if you're a parent if you're not a
parent maybe you don't know this in fact
nobody warned me of this before I before
I became a parent but when you have kids
at a certain age especially if you have
a girl there are going to be stickers
everywhere you're not going to be able
to escape stickers there'll be stickers
all over your house all over the outside
of your house all over every item you
own all over you also there's many
stickers covering you in fact that was
just I was at the grocery store last
night and I was in line and this woman
turns to me and she goes oh you're a big
Jasmine fan huh
and I said what Oh Jasmine him and she
said Jasmine from Aladdin you're a big
fan
and I said well I Aladdin was my
favorite Disney movie growing up but I
don't know how did you know that what do
you and then she points to my shirt and
I see that there's a huge sticker a huge
Jasmine sticker on my shirt which I
didn't realize was there at some point
my daughter had put a Jasmine sticker on
me without me even noticing and I had
been walking around who knows how long
with that sticker on so just something
to look out for another note completely
unrelated but I'm looking forward to
seeing hopefully some of you at the
Western conservative summit this
Thursday in Denver
June 8th is when the summit begins I'll
be speaking that morning on June 8th and
it's it'll be a great event largest
gathering of conservatives outside of DC
that happens every year and so I'll be
great to come together and talk and
learn and be equipped so hopefully
you'll you'll be able to make it out if
you live nearby now
there are
only certain kinds of life-forms that
would survive a nuclear holocaust
cockroaches famously
scorpions certain kinds of bacteria
would would would all be on that list
but I think I really believe that if the
United States were ever flattened by a
barrage of nuclear explosions and all
human life was eradicated in the country
I think that alongside the cockroaches
and scorpions and bacteria I think even
then Planned Parenthood would survive
be Planned Parenthood and cockroaches
and they would be the ones who would
survive a nuclear holocaust
and I don't look I certainly don't don't
get me wrong I would never compare
Planned Parenthood to a cockroach
because that would be grossly unfair to
cockroaches Planned Parenthood is far
far worse far lower far more disgusting
and vile than infectious bacteria or a
swarm of roaches so I would never
besmirch the good name of cockroaches in
that way and I want to apologize first
of all the cockroaches if that came
across that way at all because that's
not what I mean
what I'm saying is that the organization
of Planned Parenthood they really appear
to be essentially impervious to any kind
of attack they are they just nothing
nothing touches them
somehow
so we take this past week for example
there was this very damning report or a
report that should be damning anyway
published by live action which is a
great pro-life organization and this
report uses eyewitness accounts court
cases video footage witness our victim
testimony compiles all that together to
paint this picture to to to reveal a
fact that really is we already knew but
now they're kind of putting it all
together and showing us the scope of it
showing us that this tax-funded
abortion corporation has been engaged in
a criminal conspiracy to cover up sex
crimes
and this has been going on for a long
time
the report dates back goes back decades
to show that this is a pattern of
behavior at Planned Parenthood for a
very long time
so and I
I think it's it could be worthwhile to
just mention a few of these specific
cases just a few of these because these
are kind of emblematic of what goes on
at Planned Parenthood so just a few
cases I want to mention specifically
just so you understand first of all a
woman named Denise Fairbanks says that
she was raped and impregnated by her
father at the age of 13 he took her to a
Planned Parenthood clinic and forced her
to get an abortion
she the thirteen-year-old girl told the
clinic staff that she was being abused
they refuse to alert the authorities
fuse to do anything about it instead
they just perform the abortion they took
the money and they sent this little girl
home with her with her father so that
she could continue to be raped for
another year and a half
you
I mean just just think about that
you've got a pregnant 13 year old girl
brought to Planned Parenthood by her dad
which already should be like red flags
all over the place you've got a 13 year
old pregnant girl at being brought to an
abortion clinic by her dad so already
there should be red flags
but now she tells you she's being raped
by her father and you send her home with
her father
another case a man named the George
Savannah
was raped I should say raped and
impregnated his daughter three times
each time he brought her to Planned
Parenthood so that the evidence of his
crime would be destroyed and somehow the
fact that a man kept returning to the
clinic year after year with his daughter
who's a minor
somehow that never raised any red flags
for the Planned Parenthood staff none of
the incidents were reported nothing was
done about it the authorities were never
alerted to the situation and so the
abuse contained then another case a
twelve-year-old girl was brought to the
clinic by her foster brother who was
also her rapist Planned Parenthood this
is a 12 year old girl being brought to
the abortion clinic by her 23 year old
foster brother
which is just that right there is pretty
much it's pretty much 100% certainty
that the brother is the rapist
that's not a normal thing a 23 year old
foster brother doesn't bring his faut is
12 year old foster sister to the clinic
to get an abortion that's not something
that happens
unless the girl was raped
um
but Planned Parenthood they never
contacted the authorities they never
even contacted the girls foster parents
to let her to let them know
so the girls abuse continued
these incidents are not isolated
are widespread they're common
has made absolutely no effort to correct
that problem the problem whatsoever
Planned Parenthood was already they were
already caught on video in 2011 failing
to report the sex abuse of minors this
was a this was a sting operation that
was done you know seven years ago and
these videos came out and they got a
little bit of attention and what what
happened and in response to that they
held training sessions with their
employees to teach them how to detect if
they're being filmed
not not to teach them how to identify
and report sex crimes they didn't care
about that all they said to their
employees was what would this this is
these are the things to look out for to
know if you're being filmed
but don't worry about it for girls being
raped that's not our problem
she's filming you then this is what you
do to pretend like you do care
so Planned Parenthood has always been a
rapist best friend but it really seems
that they've fully embraced that role in
recent years and that's not to say
listen I don't believe that staff
members at your average Planned
Parenthood clinic support rape per se
I'm not saying that they like the idea
of rape necessarily I think that they
just don't care about it and they care
much more about the financial and
ideological bottom line so financially
rape is good for business so maybe in
that sense actually maybe I should
backtrack
yeah let me let me take that back I just
gave Planned Parenthood a little bit too
much credit uh no they do like right
they actually do support rape because
rape is so good for business it brings
in money and repeated rape especially
the repeated rape of a child by a family
member is extremely good for business
because it's a sustained revenue source
so when Planned Parenthood looks at a
pregnant raped thirteen-year-old girl
all they see is dollar signs they see a
sustained revenue source and they know
they're gonna get three four maybe five
abortions out of this girl but by the
time she turns 18 and so that's a lot of
money you know hey it's Christmas
bonuses for the entire staff so
financially rape is good for business
and so they're not gonna report it for
that reason
ideologically it would hurt the cause of
reproductive rights if people really
began to understand just how often women
are forced or coerced to choose
abortions
so that's why they don't want to tell us
about it because if Planned Parenthood
was honest and they actually reported
every time a girl was brought in you
know who had been a victim and it was
one of these situations where she's
being brought in and her her she's being
forced to get abortion if we could
really if we had statistics and we could
see just how often this happened we
would the entire pro-choice position
would begin to unravel
would become clear that in so many of
these cases
choice has nothing to do with it
whatsoever
so
not reporting rape means more money less
hassle reporting rape means less money
more hassle so what do you think Planned
Parenthood's gonna do they're already
killing three hundred and thirty
thousand human beings a year so what's a
little bit of rape on top of that they
what why get all squeamish about about
rape when you're killing babies every
single day you're coming to work every
single day and you're either directly
killing babies or depending on what you
do with the clinic you're facilitating
the murder of babies and this is what
you do for a living
every day you get up you know you just
stop by Starbucks you get your coffee
you head into work
maybe you pack a lunch and you go into
the break room and you punch the clock
and it's alright let's kill some babies
that's what it means to work at Planned
Parenthood so of course they're not
gonna care about rape they don't care
about anything they're just dead inside
their souls have have evaporated to
almost nothing and so I don't even think
that they're morally capable of caring
about rape even if they wanted to so
it's no surprise that Planned Parenthood
helps cover up rapes helps rapists cover
up their crimes we've known this it's
logically obvious anyway because there's
there is one incontrovertible way to
prove that for instance a father has
raped his daughter but abortion gives
the rapist scumbag father the means to
destroy that evidence and this is kind
of the morbid irony of everything is
that the abortion abortion enthusiasts
will always psyched rape and incest as
proof that abortion is necessary there
the other ones always bringing up rape
and incest rape and incest but abortion
is also precisely the thing that
empowers incestuous rapists to continue
abortion doesn't empower the victims it
empowers the Predators the victim has
already been victimized by the time the
abortion comes into play abortion is not
going to erase that all it's going to do
is create another victim but from the
perspective of the rapist abortion is
wonderful
because it means that they won't be held
accountable and they can continue raping
this is as I said rather clear it's
rather self-evident yet you might think
if you think if you didn't know any
better
you could look at the situation you
could see that yeah we've known that
Planned Parenthood's been doing this
nobody's cared up until now but maybe
now that live action is coming out with
this report and they've got it all there
you know bullet points and they've got
all the the information they've compiled
it all into one convenient place that
you can go and look and they and they're
coming out with this report in the
middle of this crusade against sexual
assault in the middle of the me2 thing
all this is going on so it seems like
society has this renewed focus on
battling sex assault and sex crimes and
so maybe if you come out with this
report now in the midst of that maybe
Planned Parenthood will finally be held
accountable for something
if you were
that then you'd be disappointed because
actually happened when when live-action
published this report last week what was
the response
nothing happened
nobody paid attention
nobody cared
we've seen this act before by the way
recall the Center for medical progress
and their sting operation at they did
against Planned Parenthood where they
were they revealed that this
organization chops up dead babies and
sells their parts they were caught on
video haggling over the price of a liver
or a kidney it was by far the most
disturbing explosive shocking undercover
footage to ever be put in front of
public or the up in front of the public
for viewing and what happened what was
the result nothing in fact you know what
the result was the Center for medical
progress got got in trouble they were
the ones who faced legal penalties not
Planned Parenthood even conservatives
couldn't seem to muster up enough energy
to focus on the on Planned Parenthood
selling dead baby parts even
conservatives couldn't seem to focus on
it for more than two days and as far as
this most recent report conservatives
didn't focus on it for even two seconds
everybody just yawned
this is how it always goes
Planned Parenthood covers up
they sell dead baby parts and oh yeah by
the way they also murder three hundred
and thirty thousand babies a year in the
first place which we all know about that
and they admit to that proudly
so that's an established fact fact
what happens as a result what what kind
of penalty what kind of social penalty
do they face because of that nothing
yeah I mean now they are gonna finally
lose a little bit of tax funding and
tiny percentage but they're still
receiving hundreds of millions of
dollars a year from the taxpayers with
no sign of that going away anytime soon
cover-up rape that can kill babies that
can sell their parts and there is
practically no social or legal
consequence for any of it
it's not that Planned Parenthood is held
to a low standard or a different
standard they are held to no standard
whatsoever they can do whatever they
want literally whatever they want
and there will not be much in the way of
popular outrage about it
how is this happening how do they get
away with everything how do they always
get away with it
how can this information be put right in
front of our faces and we just don't do
anything about it
how
at least cockroaches have the decency to
scatter when the light turns on but you
turn on the light when it comes to the
Planned Parenthood cockroach and it can
just stay there right in the light
exposing its hideous hideousness in
front of all of us and just go yeah yeah
what of it guys what are you going to do
about it
and we all say in response oh nothing
just didn't mean to disturb you go about
your business
carry on
how why I mean what is going on here
it's obvious why the left and the media
ignore this stuff that doesn't need any
explanation abortion is the sacred
sacrament on the left Planned Parenthood
is in that case kind of the high priest
and so they can not be questioned cannot
be sacre-coeur it aside they are the
sacred estava sacred cows so we get that
but what about the right
I know that there are some conservatives
on the right who are you know brimming
with rage at Planned Parenthood and who
really do care about this stuff and who
do whatever they can in their own small
way to amplify these stories and to
mobilize in response to them but they
are in the minority
that they are not that's not how it goes
in the mainstream
even among mainstream conservative
networks and mainstream conservative
commentators and pundits this issue of
Planned Parenthood abortion and so on is
basically ignored or it's treated as a
sideshow something of kind of secondary
importance
yet we know what popular outrage on the
right looks like and we also know what
can happen as a result of it so think
about the NFL for instance a few NFL
players kneeled during the anthem and
conservatives spend two years shouting
about it we had sustained outrage for
two years
conservatives boycotted a protest they
mobilized against inappropriate anthem
posture
and they and they effected change they
didn't let up about the issue
they didn't tolerate even a few NFL
players displaying inappropriate posture
during the national anthem and and and
and they hurt the NFL B I mean the NFL
was was was was hurt by the the outrage
and real change occurred
because they were so outraged so angry
so furious about it so passionate this
is what it looks like when a majority of
conservatives care about something
yet the slaughter of the unborn
Planned Parenthood chopping up babies
and selling a Planned Parenthood
covering up child rape this receives not
even a tenth not even a twentieth of the
attention or the outrage on the right
we simply don't care about it anywhere
near
the same way or to the same degree as we
cared about colin kaepernick kneeling
during the IMP
you
why I mean what why
this should be a this should be a
no-brainer
if you're not a radically pro-abortion
person you should hear stories like this
and just be I mean
yet that's not the way it goes and as I
said I know there are exceptions
but the fact remains generally speaking
conservatives just they this is just not
something that they care that much about
anecdotally okay just to give you an
anecdotal evidence last week I wrote an
article on Thursday about Samantha bee
using an inappropriate word
so Samantha B says in inappropriate she
uses a vulgarity and it was a bad word
and it was a terrible thing she said and
I thought she should be fired for it and
I still think that so I wrote an article
saying Samantha bee should be fired that
was like the title of the article and
that was that was my entire thesis
uh it's
in terms of traffic it did really well
got you know I don't know 150,000 people
read it which is which is pretty good
for a for a commentary piece
got a fair amount of attention you know
the very next day I wrote an article
about Planned Parenthood engaging in a
criminal conspiracy to cover up child
rape
which you would think is like a much
much much much much much much more
important issue yet it gets about a
third of the traffic
I get just people don't care
conservatives just care a lot more about
Samantha be using a cuss word
then they do about Planned Parenthood
I think there are two reasons I think
there's first of all just a general
apathy and moral malaise that you find
on both sides of the political spectrum
and everywhere in between people care
more about the bread and circuses types
of issues because those issues are just
easier and more fun
[Music]
just kind of these are just sort of the
shiny balls that we kind of looked to
and are distracted by the bright lights
and everything and it involves a
celebrity and so on and so forth so
or just gonna care more about that
second there's also a lack of leadership
on the right I think I mean there's a
lack of good honest leadership
because
this is just house a lot of people are
they need
it's not just conservatives but just
people in general just this is just part
of human nature
for a lot of people where they they
don't know what exactly to care about
until they're kind of told what to care
about and so we know on the left
they're generally gonna care about the
stuff that their media talking heads
tell them to care about and people on
the rights will care about whatever
FoxNews Donald Trump and various media
celebrities tell them the caribou
if those leaders
don't focus on the slaughter of the
unborn or child or Planned Parenthood
covering up child rape if they don't say
much about it which they haven't said
much about it then then a lot of
conservatives will just
ignore
I guess what I'm saying is
even though everyone likes to claim that
they think for themselves and that
they're really independent thinkers but
I think what you realize when you look
at the situation is that's actually a
very rare quality
everyone says they think for themselves
but in reality when you look at them and
you listen to them they're just saying
whatever one else says they don't think
for themselves at all
so to really think for yourself is a
very rare quality and few people possess
it
so in order to care about something like
this to care about Eva
you know abortion in general you have to
really think for yourself
mainstream media isn't going to tell you
to kid they're gonna tell you not to
care about it most conservatives ignore
it so you have to be able to look at
that look at the crowd and see that the
crowd is focused on a million things
besides this and you have to reject that
and say okay they're all they're all
clamoring about that nonsense over there
but I'm gonna focus on this because this
is what matters
the simple fact of human nature is that
very few people are willing or able to
operate that way
which is why we need leaders
who could wade into that crowd where
everyone is clamoring over nonsense and
stand up and say hey guys hold on look
what's happening over here
we just don't have enough people doing
and so Planned Parenthood gets away with
every single time they get away with it
eventually we have to stop letting
thanks for listening everybody Godspeed